beck flori karamell mit currysoße wenn
du curry marx ich liebe curry also ich
mag schon curry nur die frage ist ob ich
das auch in der kombination mag ich
glaub nicht aber ihr probiert etwas
gehabt und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut bevor wir loslegen jetzt
wahrscheinlich am liebsten gelesen es
geht heute um eure verrücktesten
fastfood kombinationen ich habe euch
gestern auch instagram nach euren ideen
gefragt
ich bin nämlich durch rob auf diese
video idee gekommen und habe ich
letztens ein video gesehen wir testen
erstens kombination irgendwie so und ich
fand es echt lustig da habe ich gedacht
da ich in letzter zeit öfter mal so ein
bisschen mit fastfood experimentiert hat
machen wir das einfach mal ähnlich nur
halt mit fast food produkten also ich
hoffe das sollte kein problem sein drops
videos in der beschreibung verlinkt und
wir fangen jetzt mal an ich muss jetzt
allerdings erstmal noch einkaufen und
dann geht es direkt los also wir sehen
uns vielleicht so leute ich bin jetzt
gerade auf dem weg wir müssen erst mal
ein paar besorgungen machen paar
einkäufe damit sich das video drehen
kann ich bin mir unsicher ob ich alles
bei einer fastfood filiale holen kann
naja manchmal checken ich denke aber das
sollte klar leute also ich war jetzt
erstmal jetzt mal im lieblings
mcdonald's der bei mir um die ecke ist
ohne spaß
ihr habt jetzt in den letzten videos
gesehen immer wenn ich da war war immer
der gleiche verkäufer im schalter drin
wenn er jetzt wieder da ist ich bin
wirklich schon davon überzeugt der
arbeiten 24 stunden sie
tage die woche also ist wirklich krass
[Musik]
alter leute das war die längste
bestellung meines lebens das hat so ewig
gedauert
okay leute ich bin wieder da ich habe
mir eben mal eure ideen angeguckt es war
ein echt eine menge und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen es war wirklich eine menge
guter ideen dabei ein paar sachen dachte
ich aber auch das ist so wirklich mac
schicken dann das fleisch runter und mc
sunday drauf und grüße mich bitte also
es das kann doch nicht schmeckt solche
sachen möchte ich auch gar nicht
ausprobieren es geht mir eigentlich nur
umso kombinationen die wirkliche sinn
ergeben könnten und die sich gar nicht
mal so eklig an hand und nein damit
meine ich nicht dieses ganz standard
typische pommes und eis weil das habe
selbst ich schon mal probiert und das
schmeckt echt gut
aber das mache wolle nicht es wird ein
bisschen ausgefallen hier haben wir die
essens produkte jetzt worden waren auch
die getränke sondern hätten wir erst mal
ein erdbeer smoothie einen milchshake
erdberg stelle das einfach mal alles
hier hin
ja so ein bisschen cola und noch einen
ice karamell dann würde ich sagen wir
lieber nicht lange ich starte mann mit
den besten ideen wenn ihr sagt alex
macht noch im zweiten teil lebt gern
noch nach oben und die erste idee kommt
von der katharina und sie hat mir
vorgeschlagen apfel tasche mit als habe
ich so noch nie probiert habe ich noch
nirgendwo gesehen deswegen test nur das
mag ich muss sagen das hat sich ja
beiden sachen mehr so um nachtisch
produkte deswegen sollte das denke ich
mal klage hier haben wir einmal eine
apfel tasche und das habt ihr ja schon
gesehen ich persönlich finde
apfeltaschen eigentlich echt lecker
deswegen würde ich mal gespannt ok
bisher komisch kann ich mir schon vor
wir bitten die apfel tasche in das eis
und ja glaubt hier muss ich sagen das
ist wirklich richtig richtig gut leute
wirklich mega lecker vor allem ich finde
die abbilder schon an
das schon gut aber mit dem eis schmeckt
das nochmal besser jetzt auf jeden fall
mal aus kann ich nur empfehlen recht ist
vorbildlich ich kann mich eigentlich es
direkt schon auf essen das ist wirklich
gut also katharina richtig gute idee
falls ihr selber irgendwie ne total
ausgefallene fastfood kombination habt
schickt mini vans oben da hab ich die
alex ii freue ich mich drauf und
eventuell gibt es irgendwann zweiten
part eventuell ich keine ahnung müssen
auch diese sache habe ich einfach mal
mit reingenommen weil ich das selber
noch nie probiert habe ich habe es aber
schon öfter mal gehört und zwar wies
burger mit pommes belegen also wir haben
wir einen ganz typischen cheeseburger
das ist doch eigentlich so der einzige
berger den ich wir haben damit ich finde
leiter man ruhig noch ein bisschen mehr
erreichen können die ist ja halb leer
ich denke das sollte fürs erste reichen
jetzt kommt der bürger drauf und so
sieht es aus also in diesem falle nichts
ausgefallenes ich denke mal dass viele
von euch schon mal probiert ich noch nie
deswegen machen wir mal kurz an sich
ganz gut nur mäßig hat ein gefallen es
ist ja eigentlich nichts anderes wenn
man im burger ist der dax in pommes
kommen ja das gleiche raus also
irgendwie von unendlich trotzdem nicht
schlecht da könnten wir eigentlich
direkt an die nächste kombination
anknüpfen wo ich sage okay das ist die
echte die wir im video machen werden ich
hab auch am anfang ein bisschen hin und
her überlegt ob ich das wirklich so
machen soll
nur komischerweise sind zwei personen
untereinander genau auf die gleiche idee
gekommen oder genau auf die gleiche
vorliebe finden schreibt bei mcdonald's
schieflage mit erdbeer shake beste
kombination duisburger mit milchshake
als kann ich mir wirklich nur schwer
vorstellen dass das irgendwie schmecken
wird aber ich probier's mal die haben
aber ich ja apple milchshake den brauche
ich gleich noch für was anderes deswegen
benutze ich das jetzt mal als löffel
also haben wir meines bürger sind sogar
noch ein paar pommes drauf und er kriegt
jetzt etwas erdberg also ich denke das
sollte reichen leute ich bin so gespannt
okay
extrem schwierig da ist die passende
antwort darauf zu finden also ich muss
sagen es schmeckt nicht schlecht so kann
man voll essen die frage ist sollte man
das zu essen ich glaube so komisch sich
das auch anders aber was fast food
angeht kann man eigentlich alles mit
allem kombiniert wir werden das
natürlich noch ein bisschen was er
herausfindet wir haben auch ein paar
wirklich sehr verrückte kombis aber das
fand ich jetzt auch überhaupt nicht
schlecht so hey leute ich bin gespannt
was als nächstes kommen aber das können
wir mal machen pommes mit erklärt musik
ist das beste ich habe ja schon gesagt
mit eis ist glaube ich so die
bekannteste kombination in apple möchte
habe ich dann auch hier deswegen so wir
haben ja drei komme ich möchte jetzt
auch nicht schlecht so aber das gefällt
mir nicht ganz so gut also die apfel
tasche mit dem 1000 mal besser keine
ahnung ist ja nur meine meinung aber das
passt sich so ganz zusammen finde ich
nur dass irgendwie verrückt dass wenn
man ein baum ist mit eis kombiniert das
dann doch irgendwie wieder passt oder
besser schmeckt obwohl das wir ja auch
irgendwie eine form von 18 keine ahnung
ich habe mir zwei kombinationen
hintereinander bekommen
die weihe currysauce enthalten ich muss
sagen curry mag ich gerne ja die frage
ist dann halt nur apfel tasche mit
currysoße
als olivia danke für den vorschlag
probiere ich gerne aus oder auch lag
flury karamell mit currysoße wenn du
curry marx ich liebe curry also ich mag
sean curry nur die frage ist ob ich das
auch in der kombination war ich glaub
nicht aber wir probieren es also wir
haben wir den körper nicht ganz gut der
kommt gleich hier rein farblich macht es
eigentlich wenig unterschied könnte man
mal seine türen schloss machen dass man
halt einfach so ein paar sachen
vertauscht zum beispiel das dann hier
curry drittes ich und meine komischen
ideen at wir müssen erstmal die apfel
tasche weiter essen bei der karibik muss
ja gleich rein also leute ich bin
gespannt
ich nehme einfach mal viel schadet ja
obwohl so viel ist jetzt auch nicht
ich glaube nicht dass es schmeckt
auf keinen fall ist bis jetzt auf jeden
fall das schlechteste vom ganzen video
das ding ist nämlich diese april tasche
hat ja sonst ziemlich süßen geschmack
und die süße geschmack wir durch diese
story total so ausgebildet und dann
schmeckt das echt komisch also das ist
eine sache die kann ich euch nicht
empfehlen ich würde auch tippen das ist
ziemlich ähnlich wenn nicht sogar noch
deutlich schlimmer wenn wir das jetzt
hier ein kippen
das tut mir echt will ok mehr nicht das
recht also wie schon eben gesagt rein
vom fachlichen her sieht man daher
absolut kein unterschiedlich verrührt
das jetzt mal ein bisschen so wie auf
dem löffel das karamell lose currysauce
und eis ist das eklig
das kann doch keiner erzählen dass ist
wirklich jemandem schmeckt also da muss
ich wirklich sagen das sind zwei arten
von lebensmitteln die sich komplett
abschluss probiert es nicht ist extrem
wirklich leute der sache die mich
wirklich extrem interessiert ist
folgendes wir haben als die sander hat
vorgeschlagen cola mit einem erdbeer
shake bei mcdonald's da war ich und das
problem aus also ja ich habe jetzt voll
aufgefüllt mit cola habe ich überhaupt
keine vorstellung von ob das was werden
kann wird wir werden sehen
das bisschen umrühren das wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so schlecht wie die es
deutlich mehr namen schokoladen
milchshake aus leute ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
also hier muss ich sagen wirklich
interessant aber nicht schlecht das
schmeckt wirklich gut komischerweise das
war ganz klar zu sagen ich habe da zwar
ist auch nur ungefähr 100 milliliter
kolar eingefüllt der erdbeergeschmack
dominiert zwar extrem dann kommt aber so
dieser coda nachgeschmack deswegen auch
hier kann ich sagen an die
experimentierfreudigen unter euch
probiert das gerne aus ich persönlich
finde es nicht schlecht
es ist jetzt nicht das beste was wir
heute hatten das war meiner meinung nach
ganz klar die apfel tasche mit dem eis
aber ich würde sagen dass personen platz
zwei hiervon habe ich jetzt auch schon
die hälfte getragen jetzt frage ich mich
aber gerade was ich dann mit dem
smoothie hier vor hatte aber aussteht
ich habe eben einen fehler gemacht der
glosse nachgeschrieben pommes mit
erdbeer ist nur die und ich habe den
erdbeermilch mitgenommen war das tut mir
leid deutet zum schluss habe ich noch
eine nachricht bekommen von lukas der
meinte junge pommes mit majo matschen
brownie für mac ist beste ich glaube er
wollte mich verarschen oder etwa so blöd
und habe mir jeden machen geholt weil
wir irgendwie keinen brownie hatten und
dann hatte ich keinen bock noch woanders
hinzufahren
ich bin doch ich habe die mario
vergessen ich will dass gerade aus dem
supermarkt gehen aber ich habe mir jetzt
gesagt okay das wird irgendwie dann auch
zu krass täglich glaube ich ich will es
eventuell im nächsten paar ausprobieren
also wenn ihr sagt alex marner raumfahrt
geben doch nach oben schreibt kommentare
oder kombination in die kommentare und
werden auch über instagram gehalt sie
alex wie das video geht wahrscheinlich
auch schon ewig deswegen war es das
bisschen ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
und wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder haut
rein aber nicht vergessen denn den
machen kann ich jetzt zu essen